nous savons que vous êtes fan de sport
mais encouragé les dites façon tout à
l'heure à notre ami sélectionneur
d'abord on est je vais avoir un mot pour
dominer aujourd'hui on a perdu
il se trouve que ce matin on a perdu un
grand sélectionneur d'un autre sport
esmonin willow d'expérience pour de
france de foot l'équipe ce matin et
dominici aussi nous a quittés il ya pour
je me suis engagé de crispation à aller
marcoussis comme je l'avais fait il y a
quelques mois mais je prends
l'engagement publiquement moi je dirais
c'est simple tous les 12 ans on est en
finale
hewitt en 2000 2001 preuve on sera tous
derrière vous mais voilà depuis on
fêtera un anniversaire important du
rugby ont fait briller en coupe on
importe ce dimanche en finale en 2020
les conflits sera pas rétabli à la
maison ou à plusieurs et exigeant
européenne fusion merci bonne demande
merci beaucoup à vous les jeunes vous
pouvez rejoindre les coulisses pour
continuer évidemment les festivités avec
nous
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
khadidja in paris marion de france des
super phone house france en allemagne au
crâne rasé this nina récupérant des
ventes rapides californie free ou big
rock band orly frappé le world challenge
en santé extrait du bar est clair au
printemps avec et ce pauvre m van sant
that is the bright side story
performance un bon vérité car c'était un
challenge sur le sport la grippe l'oms à
une story seront analysés à la balade en
forêt avec leur bassin qui leur fera du
carbone dark city et fortis à france2
france3 literie haut gradé qui m'était
dff a marre ses portes
au tpr france jeunes sujets à ce
qu'avait 22 porte aux mailles france 3
les tournées très relevé avec ses
ouailles france la tuerie
[Applaudissements]
je pense
jean bd
je ne sais pas
[Applaudissements]
dgac soit
s
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'en est-il
moment magique et encore plus à venir
que nous vivrons au sein des dix villes
hôtes à travers la france de bordeaux à
lyon donnant à saint-etienne et 2000 à
toulouse
de nice à saint denis mais aussi de
paris à marseille
le rugby est un sport très spécial qui
porte en lui des valeurs d'universalité
et d'ouverture pour comprendre un peu
mieux ce sport je vous demande
d'accueillir le directeur général de
france 2023 monsieur claude atcher
[Musique]
lod bonjour bonjour on est ravi de vous
avoir avec nous sur le plateau
aujourd'hui j'ai souvent entendu dire
que cette coupe du monde
bravo pays unique mois où les pays très
spéciaux alors elle sera unique d'abord
est unique parce que celui payé ni but
de démontrer qu'elle est la réponse à
apporter à la raison d'être d'un
événement sportif
pourquoi on organise un événement
sportif aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est
temps que les événements sportifs change
de paradigme qu'on démontre que nous
sommes ancrés dans la société que nous
avons intégré dans le cadre de
l'ambition de l'événement l'ensemble des
problématiques de cette société et que
nous voulons être exemplaire
irréprochable responsable pour démontrer
qu'un événement sportif aujourd'hui à un
impact un impact sur le pays
un impact sur la population un impact
sur le sport c'est notre travail de tous
les jours tous les jours avec mon équipe
je leur répète il faut qu'on soit
meilleur tous les jours c'est une
exigence fondamentale parce que
l'ambition que nous avons posée à des
exigences elle nous impose un certain
nombre de devoirs ses devoirs nous
essayons tous les jours de travail et
pour démontrer que cette coupe du monde
ne sera plus qu'une célébration le sera
un symbole plus que jamais je pense que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi ceux qui
nous regardent dans le monde en a besoin
de sport de fête de célébration
en quoi la coupe du monde pourrait-elle
un symbole d'espoir un monde après le
virus écoutez on a on a sept
on a cette chance également que en 2023
nous serons sûrement le premier
évènement grand sport le grand événement
sportif international qui aura lieu en
france après cette crise sanitaire
là aussi on a un devoir ce devoir c'est
de promettre aux millions de gens qui
vont regarder devant leur télévision aux
centaines de milliers de spectateurs qui
vont venir dans les stades que cette
coupe du monde elle sera différente mais
surtout qu'on leur promet une grande
fête
on leur promet un grand moment de
partage 2007 avait déjà été dans ce
cadre là
coupe du monde assez exemplaire on veut
aller plus loin on veut mettre les
joueurs au contact des spectateurs on
veut donner aux français dans les
territoires le plaisir et la joie de
retrouver le plaisir de retourner dans
un stade et je crois qu'on a un moment à
vivre ensemble maintenant à regarder
ensemble oui alors plutôt que plutôt que
des mots je vous laisse regarder les
quelques images qu'on a préparé pour
justifier cet engagement et ce
positionnement en regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça donne super envie
on a hâte d'y être exactement ça on va
être impatient trois ans on a trois ans
de travail mais je pense que tout ce que
nous avons vu c'est ce que nous voulons
donner au monde où français et à tous
les français dans quelle quelle que soit
leur situation quelle que soit l'heure
leur lieu d'habitation géographique que
cette coupe du monde des territoires
nous permettent à tous de retrouver ce
lien social que le rugby justifie
exactement dans son adn a été percé au
clos des tilleuls de mélomanes de team
fight in the woods hors du ring et tous
les dispersions event in japan
[Musique]
à
cela
[Musique]
in your drop in our capuche et aux
élèves études avec pc le monde en europe
il indiqué par cimolaï de foyot pour ce
qu'elle séjournait de barbie impliquera
pour de l'album born darracq pour le
phare après tout dans le gouvernement
aussi au niveau de la direccte pour le
croyant suez environnent bruit de
pétards explosent et je pisse et et toi
tu as menée par le crioc détruit ainsi
au mieux cet investissement et gestion
de lusine saïda flyers john's wood 6200
locaux
[Musique]
l'usiné où est une fille et lindsay
boxer aussi aux new yorkais marc ulmann
et je peux citer comme ça et ça a fait
comme si ce n'est un fax le chemin de
tubes dans une petite zone 3 words in
the artist jean dujardin
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour jean dujardin même envie
de vous avoir conçu comme ça me vend
depuis femme allait s'appliquer sur le
thème se demander qu'est ce que vous
avez appris de ces sports nautiques il a
pris ce qu'on vit un petit peu du rugby
c'est toujours un peu cliché mais en
fait c'est ce que sinon disponible de
l'engagement de combat tient son petit
ami wim à faire leur accession oui mon
pays j'étais très doué dont le plus tôt
dans le car mois après vous oublie pas
et ne tient pas c'est très bien aussi
ce genre d'outil
[Musique]
le suspense est ce qu'elle aimait tant
qu'il en soit nos banques comme le maire
jean michel wilmotte
[Musique]
et là bonjour on est ravi de vous avoir
avec nous et lui ont fait manquer
absolue les notes mais jean michel gault
everywhere bataille à coups de c
bordeaux et nice et nice paris quelque
chose seventeenth century city battu
osgood part de food for the wild things
une dizaine d'années demeurant
vichyssois sont éthiques marseille puis
comme suit i hope and the city lights
mise tout des causes profondes initiées
par cécile rauzy france ouvrira et ça
mu méditerranéenne si nous sommes un
vrai public aux designs tennis sur wii
la 206 comme si chez nous c'est du style
fantastique ce que des débats jean
michel n'a pas cherché à mettre sur de
bonnes bases face
[Musique]
africa one sound pour les we have a
c'est comme le calme au bénin qui vaille
match jean-michel you up to you in
tongues et ensuite j'en aie value in
fine au col farina npc1 de la semaine
jean michel denisot nationale américain
tout à marcoussis où nkou 10 5 qui
seulement choumicha pas fait part de son
pote et china road and foremost please
welcome à fait au goût fin 12 voix haute
et salah à ce que me barre beaucoup de
planètes fondation monsieur yann arthus
bertrand
[Musique]
bien arthus-bertrand bonjour on est
vraiment très très heureux de vous avoir
avec nous sur le plateau aujourd'hui
your eyes smith chesney joe kay problème
avec whitehead spécifique ligne the
world la semaine dernière le secrétaire
général des nations unies a lancé un
appel au secours que nous allions vers
une crise climatique imminente très
importante et c'est le secrétaire
général des nations unies s'est pas le
patron de greenpeace ou de verdon
vraiment faut croire les scientifiques
aujourd'hui et pourquoi parce que bien
sûr beaucoup de grands joueurs de rugby
viennent petite île du pacifique tonga
fidji qui risque un jour d'être inondés
dont bien sûr vous êtes en plein dedans
est ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
tout être humain aujourd'hui a le devoir
d'essayer d'agir contre le changement
climatique a ça dans sa vie quotidienne
c'est un devoir qu'on a tous tout être
humain
chacun a sa part à jouer en effet
exactement
et vous vous avez un rôle à jouer tout
de suite il y en a on va commencer avec
inquiet
américain one américain one in four et
clis
on enchaîne asia pacific one et je
pensais fait quoi et pour des clis un
exxon europe
wam your are one in pousser un cri and
half dollar sont aussi amis à wasmes
oceania one faut tout d un qui s'amorce
avec tyan one de fonds publics pour me
banbanaste un clic le fanal communiqué
ils sont ravis de ce secteur une
exception la porte dorée une paresse et
christian louboutin
[Musique]
question ravi de vous avoir sur le plan
politique
[Musique]
et tous les impôts est we have et il est
vrai qu'en y en a une pour baby non j'ai
bien fidji poser à de la spa argentine
christina hembo des parfaits pendant que
je suis une panne qui se mobilisent
comme amber sans fil machine au ballet
l'opéra de paris à deux pas donges la
presse locale suivi sportif de miss
france
jurrjens suis pas une machine please
welcome alice renavand
[Musique]
aller très très heureuse de vous avoir
dans le rugby c'est la danse c'est ce
que vous êtes d'accord
c'est amusant mais pourquoi bouder une
danse explosive
vraiment limite violentes parfois c'est
vrai j'ai dit oui quand je regardais le
rugby je vois une vraie chorégraphie les
schémas tactiques sont vraiment des
figures qu'on peut retrouver vraiment
dans nos belles et qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous alice voir sur le tyran en
2023 de l'émotion là en plus on en a
vraiment besoin
en plus j'aime vraiment autant regarder
le sport que la danse vraiment
l'investissement des joueurs le
dépassement de soi voilà sont des choses
auxquelles je tiens énormément et de les
voir voilà tous se battent pour leur
nation je trouve ça vraiment incroyable
et bien super on va démarrer donc sept
tirs à charroux et united island
c'est vrai le pur bis av
allenby dans australia une poussée
australien à nexon japan
je parle beaucoup des banderoles en
dollars pour ce couple qui souhaitait
pourtant est à micheline chef guy savoy
mais [ __ ]
[Musique]
et bien qu'elle plateau quel bonheur
c'est super de vous avoir avec nous guy
savoy
enfin est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer comment le rugby a influencé
votre vie votre carrière
ma vie bombay dès l'école de rugby j'ai
pris conscience qu'en équipe on était
bien plus fort j'ai pris également
conscience que malgré toutes les
singularités de chaque poste à dire
toutes les différences à la votre
personnalité de physique de vitesse
grâce à toutes ces différences en feu
en fait on faisait une équipe cohérente
et je me suis aperçu aujourd'hui enfin
je mets ça en place dans dans mes
restaurants et on voit que chaque
personne a toujours un poste qui lui
convient et ce grâce à on l'apprend
rugby
trois cas dans votre restaurant aussi
vous n'avez pas une brigade mais plutôt
une équipe c'est ça j'ai toujours
défendu lui-même critique absolument ça
c'est certainement lié directement au
rugby et j'ai aussi par habitude de dire
que dans cette équipe je suis le
capitaine entraîneur
malheureusement parfois larbitre mais
très rarement très très bien alors c'est
l'heure de jouer
ça bouge un peu dans la salle et un
petit peu d'excitation
c'est normal news il a dit oui
[Musique]
england npd a dit anna bligh
on est juste rajouter ce que dit bernard
laporte figurent les voilà il est 13
heures 14 merci d'être avec nous en ce
lundi 14 décembre bonjour arnaud coudry
reporter au service des sports du figaro
sport24 pour le figaro.fr spécialistes
rugby on vient de suivre le tirage au
sort des groupes pour le mondial 2022 3
on les voit juste derrière nous on va
vous voulez remontrer c'est ses poules
avec la france qui affrontera la
nouvelle zélande
tirage qu'on craignait est en fait tombé
dessus
merci guy savoy merci qui savoir des
plus grands chefs étoilés on aurait
peut-être eu plus de chance avec
philippe etchebest que les fans de rugby
lui aussi mais du coup donc la nouvelle
zélande mais c'est ce qu'on peut lire
dans un papier de david reyrat il ya une
des personnalités qu'on a vu sur ce
plateau tout à l'heure qui disait ben
oui mais si on joue un gros en poule on
le retrouve pas avant la finale voilà
c'est ce qui s'était passé à la coupe du
monde 2015 ou en fait on avait joué
contre les all blacks en match de poule
on avait pris une dérouillée et ça nous
avait pas empêchés de les retrouver en
finale et de perdre seulement un point
donc c'était c'est déjà arrivé qu'on
croise les all blacks dès les phases de
poules quoi le tirage au sort
bon ça se termine on aperçoit bernard
laporte on va vous montrer aussi dans
quelques minutes la conférence de presse
ont fait un petit débrief ans on va
écouter bernard la porte et on se
retrouve juste après quel est votre
ressenti après cette très belle reste
d'abord permettez moi au nom de la
fédération internationale et en tant que
vice président au nom de bill beaumont
notre moto de sherman de remercier le
président de la république qui nous a
fait honneur à fait honneur au rugby
international
qui plus est c'est évidemment bien sûr
que nous organisons donc merci à lui
d'être d'être venu et merci à claude
il ya toutes les équipes parce que
c'était une cérémonie formidable décors
extraordinaires qui donne envie je
disais tout à l'heure la coupe du monde
elle démarre aujourd'hui voilà on
connaît tout le monde connaît ses
adversaires
c'est le premier jour de la coupe du
monde francophone
because it français veulent une france
ouest france il n'y a pas de bonne ou de
mauvaise surprise
je crois qu'aujourd'hui des équipes vont
pouvoir commencer à se projeter sur
cette compétition aujourd'hui était un
jour important mais juste si j'ai un
petit conseil à donner à un geek tirer
la nouvelle zélande voilà il ne faudrait
pas qu'ils croissent trop de joueurs
français pendant trois ans parce que
peut-être être compliqué pour lui voilà
pour les réactions arnaud coudry bond en
avant grâce aux différents niveaux de
français pas de nos français justement
on peut assez facilement comprendre ce
qui se dit bon
quelle réaction on peut avoir après ce
tirage au sort je vois dans le tchat sur
lefigaro.fr il ya le vieux loup du 83
qui je dis bonjour tiens qui nous dit
aïe
on aurait là on a vu la nouvelle zélande
est un public il ya quand même deux
équipes qui sortent de chaque poule donc
derrière il ya l'italie
l'américain et l'afrique 1 cd équipe
relativement faible lorsque vous voyez
nous explique arnaud ce que c'est
américains oea africaine mais en fait il
ya des zones de qualification à travers
le monde qui amérique afrique il ya des
confrontations asie pacifique et à
chaque fois il ya plusieurs équipes qui
s'affrontent pour décrocher un billet
donc je vous cache pas que c'est un peu
une usine à gaz un peu incompréhensible
mais en tout cas il ya par région
géographique différents billets qui sont
attribués il y en a deux en amérique en
afrique on a vu donc ces deux os sinon
une en une
donc c'est un peu partout à travers le
monde ya encore des équipes qui
bataillent pour décrocher leur billet
pour aller à la coupe du monde alors
qu'il savait très loin puisque le
tournoi de qualification il y en a un
qui il ya un dernier tournoi de
qualification entre fin 2022 chemin
voilà c'est ça donc ça valait vraiment
au bout du bout du bout pour aller à la
coupe du monde quoi qui ça pourrait être
ses adversaires jean reno américain donc
non américains il ya des fortes chances
que ce soit soit le canada soit les
états unis où soit l'uruguay qui avait
fait un peu une surprise à la dernière
coupe du monde qui avait réussi à battre
les fidji donc ça c'est l'américain ça
devrait être ces trois équipes là et
africain il ya de très fortes chances
que ce soit la namibie qui est présente
à toutes les coupes du monde n'a pas
gagné un match je crois la coupe du
monde ou très peu mais qui est là
toujours présente
il ya toujours l'afrique du sud qui est
la grande équipe du continent africain
et derrière c'est la namibie qui est
voisins d'afrique du sud qui est souvent
et presque tout le temps l'équipe
la deuxième équipe africaine qualifiée
ces deux là c'est très très abordable
franchement italie enfin à part les all
blacks où ça va vraiment être un gros
match un test très important
sinon les autres les autres équipes
c'est très très abordable la france a
été et est assez épargnée canton
regardez tout à l'heure les autres
poules je pense que la poule d où il ya
l'angleterre le japon et l'argentine
c'est très très très relevé quoi et
océanie un ça va être soit les tonga sur
les samoa
donc c'est à mon avis de loin le ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la poule de la
mort je pense parce qu'après a c'est
vrai que la poule c est relevé aussi
avec les pour les gallois ils sont pas
très bien actuellement mais quand même
l'australie ont toujours s'en méfier et
les fidji donc c'est assez costaud aussi
et je pense que la laddh et c'est celle
qui est la plus la plus relevé la plus
compliquée quoi il ya coco vallecano dit
sur lefigaro.fr les avoir en poule ce
n'est plus les rencontrer avant la
finale on parle des néo zélandais mais
mais avant ça il y aurait peut-être il y
aura certainement aussi déjà on va se
focaliser sur la poule puisque c'est le
tirage au sort des groupes aujourd'hui
la france doit au moins terminer
deuxième sim énorme échec si nos hommes
et c'est ce que je vous le disais c'est
franchement c'est tout à fait enfin
c'est leur âge tout à fait clément le
courage qu aurait pu être le plus
clément sait si on avait pris le pays de
galles plutôt que la nouvelle zélande
là ils ont été très facile là on a un
gros mais si on avait pris l'afrique du
sud où l'angleterre s'était quand même
très très comprend est compliqué de
terminer premier de la poule mais si on
est deuxièmes de poule on sort on va en
quarts et puis rappelons que la france
n'a jamais de finale et justement qui
est ce qu on pourrait alors au regard de
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui puisque sur 20
équipes qui vont disputer cette
compétition 2023 en france on le
rappelle est bien aujourd'hui on n'a que
douze noms qui est ce que l'équipe de
france pourrait retrouver en quarts de
finale où c'est parce qu'elle serait là
mais la logique
la poule à fond de la poule b où cissé à
se croiser avec la poule c où la poule d
en tout cas la france pourrait battre si
la france termine 2e de sa poule
derrière les all blacks
elle affrontera le 1er du nom de poule
c'est là où c'est où c'est un peu
compliqué
[Musique]
il faudra
quand du trou
fait de faux
[Musique]
rien
remonté à la quatrième place donc elle
aurait été tête de série à la place du
pays de galles et elle n'aurait pas eu à
affronter les all blacks par exemple
c'est un peu rageant mais on était enfin
le savez quoi
ah oui alors on entend le son de la
vidéo voir le rugby désolé à toutes et
tous
oui effectivement ça on n'a plus les
images en direct du palais brogniart là
où se situe la bourse puisque en 98 là
où s'est déroulé le tirage au sort
emmanuel macron vous l'avez vécu on a
commencé ce direct là-dessus emmanuel
macron s'est exprimée en ouverture et
bien de ce tirage au sort juste avant
que les bulls ne soit tirée par des
personnalités comme comme jean dujardin
christian louboutin est un oui là il a
dit aussi il a dit on va d'abord parlé
de cet hommage quelques mots en hommage
à christophe dominici arno christophe
dominici qui nous a quittés brutalement
récemment ça a été un choc pour la
planète
la planète rugby dans son ensemble
toutes les nations on pressent que j'ai
souvenir de deux tweets dommage de la
fédération néo-zélandaise de la
fédération anglaise était un joueur qui
était connu dans le monde entier et puis
qui était qui et qui représentait
vraiment une l'image du french flair
quelque part le côté imprévisible un peu
voilà on sait pas ce qu'il va faire elle
va débloquer la partie
c'était un joueur qui était connu dans
le monde entier et puis christophe
dominici puisqu'on parle de coupe du
monde de rugby c'est cette finale de 99
ouais c'est ça la demi finale contre les
all blacks à domicile
et ils marquent un essai est superbe
avec le petit coup de pied là par dessus
de fabien galthié mais on oublie aussi
qu'il ya un essai avance et 3 christophe
lamaison qui le marque mais il fait une
action géniale
oui slalom complètement dans la défense
des all blacks et il fait un match
monstrueux journal et il a vraiment
marqué l'histoire du rugby ce jour là
quoi on a un internaute avec un pseudo
deux petits points qui nous dit de toute
façon pour devenir champion du monde il
faut battre tout le monde c'est une
alors je ne sais pas si on l'attribué à
bernard laporte mais c'est bernard
laporte vous pouvez d'ailleurs autres
cette citation d'un article de david
reyrat sur sport24 point le figaro.fr
c'est une citation de bernard laporte
justement emmanuel macron qu'elle est
c'est bizarre de dire ça qu'on peut être
champion du monde il faut battre tout le
monde
je vous rappelle qu en 2011 la coupe du
monde 2011
oui on perd en finale d'un point ce
qu'est le meilleur résultat de
l'histoire de la france ces neuf à huit
je crois 808 7,8 satwa examinerait ton
perdre seulement d'un point contre les
all blacks
mais en match de poule on a perdu contre
les all blacks et contre les tonga donc
c'est à dire qu'on a perdu deux matches
et on est quand même en finale et on est
à deux fois rien de plus oui donc
finalement on voit que ça s'applique pas
forcément tout le temps mais c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être plus la règle en
rugby qu'en foot par exemple mais c'est
ça on avait aussi récemment là que la
france va jouer contre les all blacks en
novembre prochain
l'an prochain on va la gloire les all
blacks au stade de france ça fait
longtemps qu'on les a pas joués
et puis il ya trois ans c'était en l'été
2018 je crois et surtout on les a pas
battus depuis 2009 et on reste sur
quatorze défaites d'affilée contre les
all blacks quand même donc ça serait
bien de marquer le coup et de
à l'inversé un peu la tendance est un
test très important je pense et emmanuel
macron qui a aussi rappelé il vous a
coupé l'herbe sous le pied parce que
vous allez nous parler de cette stat
arnaud et ce qui t'es là dessus la
france est bien tous les 12 ans accède à
la finale
c'est ça depuis la création de la coupe
du monde en 1987 la france est en finale
tous les 12 ans donc 1987 défaite contre
les all blacks 99 défaite contre
l'australie après avoir battu les all
blacks en demi finale 2011 des fêtes
concours de la longueur d'un seul petit
point
et voilà et 12 ans plus tard ça nous
emmène à 2023 donc est ce qu'on sera en
finale est ce qu on inversera la
tendance
cette fois ci pour de bon on verra on
verra ce qu'en disent aussi les
bookmakers ainsi ils sont habitués à
prendre ce genre de logique pour établir
les cotes en tout cas voilà on rappelle
la france nouvelle zélande l'italie et
puis deux adversaires encore à définir
en tout cas ce qu'ont son vent est
certain c'est qu'il y aura un adversaire
issu d'amérique du nord ou du sud et un
autre adversaire issu du continent
africain tout ça pour le groupe le
groupe à de la france dans cette coupe
du monde de rugby le mondial 2023 qui
aura lieu sur le sol français
on sait que ce sont les bleus qui vont
jouer le premier match au stade de
france va nous rappeler des mauvais
souvenirs parce que donc en 2007 match
d'ouverture contre l'argentine on perd
on perd contre l'argentine ça fait que
grosso modo on est condamné à être a
tout gagné au havre et à devoir aller
affronter les all blacks à cardiff en
ouvrant au pays de galles
donc c'était un peu tout le monde se
disait pour bah ça y est c'est des all
blacks elle c'est fini on va perdre et
c'était un des plus grands exploits
encore de du 15-2 vivait à battre les
all blacks qui était archi favori encore
ils sont toujours très très favoris mais
mais cette fois ci c'était parce qu'on
avait perdu le match d'ouverture de
notre coupe du monde à domicile qu'on
s'est retrouvé à devoir aller jouer à
cardiff contre les all blacks
incroyable c'était on a été éliminé en
demi finale contre l'angleterre
c'est ça avec la coupe du monde jonny
wilkinson
et côté de l'angleterre qui à l'époque
cartonné je crois qu'il joue encore tout
n'était pas encore arrivé mais les
coupes du monde 2003 et 2007 c'est jonny
wilkinson qui nous ont précisé des
matches il passe des droits pénalité il
est impeccable
c'est un joueur fantastique une question
du figaro sur fillon préfère après le
brésil l'angleterre va-t-elle encore
participer à la coupe d'europe
alors je sais pas si on parle là du
tournoi des six nations une en europe
des clubs
je pense qu'on devait plus sur la coupe
d'europe des clubs et même pour le
tournoi des six nations qui intègre à
rien et ça changera rien c'est pas parce
qu'économiquement ils sortent de
l'europe que sportivement ils vont
sortir des compétitions statu quo merci
à toutes et à tous d'avoir suivi ce
tirage au sort et se débrief en direct
merci arnaud coudry d'avoir été au bout
on retrouve aux productions ainsi que
celle de m
et tout est bien tout les articles de
l'équipe de sport 24 sur sport24 point
le figaro.fr vous devez filet puisqu'il
ya des conférences de presse qui vont
suivre
et bien ce tirage au sort merci très
bonne journée à toutes et à tous et puis
une excellente interview de kevin
escoffier aussi retrouvé qui a été fait
sous l'évier en direct ce matin le
navigateur vous pouvez retrouvez
également sur sport24 pour le figaro.fr
très bonne journée très bonne semaine à
toutes et à tous au revoir